Guten Tag wieder. Wie heißen Sie?
Ich heiße Miriam Becker.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen und Nachnamen langsam beschreiben?
Ja, der Vorname ist M-I-R-I-A-M Miriam.
Und der Familienname ist Becker.
Vielen Dank, Frau Becker. Wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 36.
36. Wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 2.05.1990.
Entschuldigung, noch mal bitte.
Am 2.05.1990. Also am 2. Mai 1990.
Ok, vielen Dank. Und wie groß sind Sie und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich bin 1,71 Meter und ich wiege 64 Kilo.
64 Kilo. Vielen Dank, Frau Becker. Was führt Sie heute zu uns?
Ja, wissen Sie, ich habe seit einigen Tagen solche unglaublichen Schmerzen im Bauch, und zwar so im Oberbauchbereich.
Ja, und ich habe so ein bisschen die Befürchtung, das fing an nach einem Essen in einem thailändischen Restaurant, da war das Essen sehr scharf gewürzt.
Ich habe das total unterschätzt. Ich habe mich da auch verschluckt und das brannte wie Feuer.
Es war sehr scharfes Essen. Und oh, danach hatte ich dann mit einem mal wirklich sehr starke Schmerzen.
Und das krampfte sich dann nachher alle so zusammen. Also furchtbar.
Und jetzt ist mir also immer noch schlecht und ich kann noch immer nicht, also nicht richtig was Herzhaftes essen.
Ich kann also nur das, was ich so wirklich schonen kostet, zu mir nehmen. Alles andere, da tut mir der Bauch total weh.
Wann haben die Schmerzen angefangen?
Vor drei Tagen. Also direkt nach dem Essen.
Okay. Nach dem Essen besonders, scharf dem Essen.
Ja, also da ist das so richtig losgegangen. Ja, weil es seither nicht besser geworden ist, habe ich gedacht, ich muss mal drinnen mich vorstellen bei Ihnen.
Im Laufe der Zeit verstärkt die Oberbauchschmerzen?
Ja, verstärkt vielleicht nicht, aber eigentlich überhaupt nicht besser geworden.
Ja, okay. Gibt es etwas bestimmtes beim Essen? Was die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Oder gibt es bestimmte Seiten, was die Schmerzen lindert oder verstärkt?
Also, ich...
Nach dem Essen, vor dem Essen oder in der Nacht?
Also, was ich merke, wenn ich eben versuche, ein bisschen mehr zu essen als ganz leichte Schonkost, da habe ich weder Appetit noch kann ich das ertragen.
Also, da würden die Schmerzen schlechter. Aber ich habe gar keine Lust oder ich traue mich gar nicht, irgendwas Herzhaftes zu essen.
Und ich habe jetzt also nur gekochtes Gemüse gegessen und was weiß ich, mal eine Banane und ein bisschen Pudding und mal Joghurt, aber irgendwie nichts Deftiges halt.
Besonders ist Joghurt als Banane nach diesem Lebensmittag die Schmerzen verbessern.
Ja, aber sie werden jedenfalls nicht schlimmer.
Okay. Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder nur manchmal?
Eigentlich sind die schon ziemlich ständig da und das krampft so richtig in den Bauch. Also, das gibt immer so Wellen.
Krampferartig und wellenformig. Und so stauen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Ja, das ist hier oben so oberhalb vom Bauchnabel würde ich sagen. Da sitzen die Schmerzen, aber die Strahlen, die sind davor verortet, die strahlen nicht aus.
Okay. Ja, sind die Schmerzen im Mittelpunkt oder rechts oder links oder links?
Also, ich würde sagen, die sind in der Mitte, da merke ich die.
Haben Sie Zotbränen oder Sauerstoff bemerkt?
Was habe ich bemerkt?
Haben Sie Zotbränen vor oder nach dem Essen oder Sauerstoff?
Sauerstoff? Also, ich musste mich zweimal richtig übergeben heute Morgen. Das war auch ganz unangenehm.
Und ich habe auch, also, ja, eigentlich fing das auch schon an, dass ich ziemlich bald nach dem Essen ordentlich Durchfall hatte.
Bedurft war.
Ja, ja, so als ob der ganze Körper reagiert auf dieses verkehrte Essen. Also, das mit dem Durchfall, das fing eigentlich schon ganz schnell an.
Und übergeben musste ich mich dann heute. Und ja, natürlich, das war natürlich eklig sauer und da war auch dann eigentlich nicht mehr viel Material.
Okay. Wann haben Sie Durchfall? Langgefangen?
Das hat direkt, also ziemlich direkt nach dem Essen, seit drei Tagen.
Wie oft haben Sie Durchfall?
Ich gehe bestimmt fünf, sechsmal am Tag auf die Toilette.
Okay. Und nach dem Essen haben Sie übergeben oder müssen Sie übergeben? Nach dem Essen müssen Sie...
Übergeben habe ich mich erst heute das erste Mal.
Na, erst einmal. Ja, okay. Zweimal.
Heute Morgen zweimal, ja.
Ja. Total zweimal oder mehrmals?
Nee, insgesamt zweimal. Das war heute.
Okay. Haben Sie Fieber?
Ich habe mich nicht gemessen, aber ich glaube nicht, also ich fühle mich jetzt nicht richtig fiebrig.
Also mir ist nur schlecht.
Leiden Sie früher eine Schmerzen oder eine Beschwerden gehabt?
Ja, also ich war tatsächlich vor einem halben Jahr bei meinem Hausarzt und der hat da was im Magenspiegelung gemacht, der konnte aber nichts finden.
Und ja, warum bin ich da gewesen? Weil ich eben auch Bauchschmerzen hatte und dann hat man aber eigentlich nichts gefunden.
Und dann hat er gesagt, das liegt wahrscheinlich am Stress.
Haben Sie dagegen Medikamente eingenommen damals oder nehmen Sie Regenmiss dagegen?
Nee, nee. Dadurch, dass da nichts erkennbar war, habe ich auch keine Medikamente bekommen.
Ja, okay.
Er hat eigentlich gesagt, ja Ruhe und Stress abbauen und sowas.
Ja, Stress abbauen besonders.
Haben Sie in letzter Zeit privaten oder beruflichen Stress?
Ja, also beruflich hat man sowieso immer Stress, weil immer alles Termingeschichten sind und privat, naja also, nee Stress würde ich das nicht nennen.
Ja, okay. Und Sie haben immer dauerhaft Stress, ich denke das.
Bei der Arbeit immer ein bisschen, aber ja, so schlimm finde ich es jetzt eigentlich nicht.
Ja, okay. Haben Sie Fieber, haben Sie Stiftfrost und Gewichtfibris in letzter Zeit?
Nee, also Schüttelfrost hatte ich nicht. Und dann hätte ich, wenn ich Schüttelfrost gehabt hätte ich auch Fieber gemessen.
Nee, das war eigentlich nicht. Und Gewicht, nee das ist eigentlich schon lange stabil.
Ja, Nachtschwachs?
Nachtschwitz, naja gut, als es jetzt so heiß war habe ich nachts geschwitzt, aber ich glaube da hat jeder geschwitzt, ja.
Ja, okay. Haben Sie deswegen einen anderen Arzt aufgesucht?
Ja, vor einem halben Jahr, wie gesagt da war ich bei meinem Hausarzt.
Und der hat eben diese Magenspiegelung gemacht und hat gesagt, er kann nichts finden und ich soll mal ein bisschen ruhig werden.
In den letzten drei Tagen haben Sie einen anderen Arzt aufgesucht?
In den letzten drei Tagen war ich noch nicht, nein das ist ja Urlaubszeit, mein Hausarzt ist im Urlaub.
Ja, haben Sie, wie sieht der Stuhlgang aus?
Wie der aussieht? Ja, wie so durchfallen das aussieht, so wässrige Flüssigkeit, ein bisschen Schleim durchsetzen und ein bisschen Essenreste drin, ja.
Haben Sie Blutbeinmengungen nicht bemerkt?
Das habe ich nicht bemerkt? Blutbeinmengungen im Stuhl nicht bemerkt?
Blut, nein, nein, nein, nee, das wäre mir aufgefallen, blutig war das nicht.
Sie haben gesagt, zweimal weggeben, haben Sie bemerkt, dass in erbrochenen Blutbeinmengungen oder Essenreste oder Kaffeesatzartige Farbe übergegeben wurde.
Also das waren Essenreste, was ich erbrochen habe und so ein bisschen Magensaft, aber Blut, nein, das habe ich nicht gesehen.
Ja, was sind Sie, Frau Mbeka? Ich bin Werbegrafikerin. Werbegrafiker, ok. Vielen Dank.
Leiden Sie an chronischen Erkrankungen, Zuckerkrankheit, Bluthochdruck oder erhöhten Blutzeit bei der Farbe?
Also ich habe tatsächlich ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck, ja, obwohl ich noch nicht so alt bin, also das ist ein bisschen nervig, ja.
Aber vor zwei Jahren hat man das festgestellt und seitdem nehme ich so einen Beta Blocker.
Ja, Beta Blocker. Wissen Sie, was das Medikament heißt?
Wie das heißt? Das ist Nebivolol. Welche Dosierung? 2,5 oder nehme ich morgens ein?
Ja, 2,5, das frage ich mich. Und andere Medikamente nehmen Sie regelmäßig ein?
Nein, die Pille nehme ich noch, aber ja, da muss ich diesen Monat natürlich trotzdem aufpassen,
weil ich mich übergeben habe und Durchfall hatte, schützt die mich ja im Augenblick nicht.
Ok. Haben Sie regelmäßige Monatblutung?
Eigentlich, ja, durch die Pille ist es halt ganz regelmäßig, ne?
Ja, ok. Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich bin verheiratet.
Ja, haben Sie Kinder?
Ein Kind habe ich.
Gesund?
Die ist gesund, ja, das Kind ist gesund.
Ok. Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Ja, also als Kind schon lange her, da hatte ich mal die Mandeln rausbekommen.
Mandeln, ja. Ok. Als Kind halt. Andere Operation? Sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Nein, sonst?
Nein, ich bin mal gesund geblieben, ja.
Gibt es keine Kaiserschnitz?
Bitte was?
Kaiserschnitz, Kaiserschnitz.
Nein, nein, das ist spontan auf die Welt gekommen.
Ok. Haben Sie Allergie oder Unferträglichkeiten?
Ja, ich habe eine krasse Allergie auf Erdnüsse.
Also die darf ich überhaupt nicht essen.
Und auch nichts, wo Erdnüsse drin sind oder so. Da muss ich immer ziemlich aufpassen.
Krasse Allergie und Erdbierallergie habe ich?
Nein, nein, nein. Nur Erdnüsse.
Nur Erdnüsse, entschuldigung.
Ah, ich habe eine krasse Allergie.
Ja, krasse.
Also eine heftige Reaktion auf Erdnüsse, ne?
Ja, wie Du sagt.
Ja, also ich kriege total geschwollene Schleimhäute und auch Luftnot. Also das geht überhaupt nicht.
Luftnot und Krasse.
Rauchen Sie oder haben Sie früher geraucht?
Nein, also man muss ja nicht alle Laster haben. Aber rauchen tue ich tatsächlich nicht.
Entschuldigung, was hat Sie gesagt? Ich habe die Internetverbindung verpasst.
Also ich habe noch nie geraucht.
Ok, ja. Trinken Sie Alkohol regelmäßig oder manchmal?
Ja, also zwei bis drei Mal in der Woche trinke ich abends ein Glas Rotwein.
Ein oder zwei Glas Wein.
Ok.
Das ist die Routinefrage. Konsumiert Sie Drogen oder früher haben Sie Drogen konsumiert?
Nein, also auch in meinen wildesten Zeiten habe ich keine Drogen konsumiert.
Sind Ihre Eltern gesund?
Ja, die sind natürlich auch schon alt. Meine Mutter hat jetzt seit drei Jahren diesen Alterstucker festgestellt.
Und mein Vater, der ist eigentlich auch noch relativ fit, der hat aber eben auch einen hohen Blutdruck.
Und der hatte neulich mal ganz plötzlich Probleme. Da hatte der so Vorhochflimmern.
Aber das hat sich Gott sei Dank wieder gegeben.
Gleichzeitig hatte ich einen hohen Blutdruck.
Und der hat einen hohen Blutdruck, ja.
Ok, ja.
Leiden Sie irgendwelche Erkrankungen in Ihrer Familie? Besonders das Magengeschwür oder so?
Na ja, so viel ich weiß nicht. Aber die Frage ist, wo diese Schmerzen herkommen.
Ok.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen, Frau Becker?
Nein, eigentlich nicht.
Verspüren Sie Schmerzen oder?
Nein, nein, nein. Eigentlich komme ich gut schlafen.
Schlafen Sie gut? Haben Sie Probleme einzuschlafen oder durchzuschlafen?
Ja, also manchmal habe ich Probleme mit dem Einschlafen, wenn ich ein bisschen unruhig bin oder so.
Aber eigentlich kann ich meistens ziemlich gut schlafen.
Aber jetzt mit den Bauchschmerzen natürlich nicht so gut, ne?
Ja, Entschuldigung, das habe ich vergessen.
Wie lange dauert es, wenn die Schmerzen zurückkommen?
Wie lange dauert es? Sie haben gesagt, es ist krampfartig.
Die besonders schlimmste Zeit, wie lange dauert es, wenn ich Bauchschmerzen habe, können Sie mir sagen.
Das sind wahrscheinlich so Wellen von 5 Minuten oder so.
Ja, ok. 5 Minuten.
Ich kann das nicht gut einschätzen.
Ok, ja, vielen Dank.
Entschuldigung, das habe ich vergessen.
Wie stark sind Schmerzen auf einer Skala von 1 bis 10, wobei 1 ein sehr leichter und 10 ein erträglicher Schmerz?
Also, wenn das so gerade sich zusammenkommt, dann sind das schon sehr heftige Schmerzen.
Würde ich vielleicht sagen, schon über die Hälfte auf alle Fälle.
Also normal ist es so bei 5, zwischen 5 und 7 würde ich sagen.
Ok, vielen Dank.
Frau Becke, habe ich die wichtigste Frage schon gestellt.
Und möchten Sie etwas hinzufügen?
Ja, ich will natürlich wissen, was dahinter steckt und was man dagegen tun kann.
Und ob ich möglicherweise in der Klinik bleiben muss, weil ich mich dann ja um meine Familie...
Es muss ja irgendwie alles geklärt werden.
Da muss ich ja Kontakt aufnehmen.
Mein Mann hat mich zwar gebracht, aber ist dann zu unserer Tochter nach Hause gefahren.
Und ich muss den ja informieren, wie es weitergeht.
Frau Becke, jetzt kann ich nicht ganz genau sagen, was Sie haben.
Aber ich denke, Sie müssen im Krankenhaus nicht bleiben.
Oh, das ist gut, ja.
Ich denke das. Aber zuerst muss ich Sie körperlich untersuchen.
Dann kann ich Sie körperlich untersuchen und dann kann ich Sie mit dem Ultraschall durchführen.
Ultraschall ist ja nicht so schlimm. Das kenne ich ja aus der Schwangerschaft.
Das ist ja nicht schlimm.
Und wenn die Ergebnisse kommen, können wir miteinander sprechen.
Ah ja, das klingt vernünftig. Okay, gut. Wo kann ich denn jetzt so erstmal warten?
Wo kann ich warten? Soll ich im Wartezimmer Platz nehmen oder...?
Ja, ja, ja. Warten Sie bitte im Untersuchungszimmer.
Im Untersuchungszimmer, dann kann ich hier...
Ja, im Untersuchungszimmer. Und bitte legen Sie auf die Untersuchungszene.
Ich komme gleich.
Sehr gut. Okay, ja, dann mache ich das so. Alles klar.
Ja, vielen Dank, Frau Becke.
So hat von den Kolleginnen und Kollegen noch jemand zusätzlich eine Frage.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Frau Becke? Oder Brustrasen?
Nein, Herzrasen, enge Gefühl.
Nein, sowas habe ich nicht.
Danke schön.
Ja, guten Abend.
Haben Sie Schwierigkeiten im Stuhlgang?
Na ja, jetzt im Augenblick habe ich halt Durchfall.
Aber eigentlich normalerweise...
Ja, wie gesagt, ich habe das jetzt schon häufiger mal gehabt,
dass ich so ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen hatte und dann habe ich auch mal ein bisschen Durchfall.
Aber so heftig jetzt eigentlich nicht.
Also hin und wieder habe ich mal Durchfall, ja.
Frau Becke, fühlen Sie sich schwach oder müde?
Na ja, jetzt schon eigentlich.
Also einmal, weil ich nicht viel gegessen habe und weil mir dauernd schlecht ist.
Und auch weil ich heute Nacht nicht so gut geschlafen habe.
Sind Sie schwinderlich?
Mir ist nicht schwinderlich, nein.
Danke.
Frau Becke, wie ist Ihr Stuhl aus?
Ja, das habe ich ja gesagt.
Also der Kollege hat das ja gefragt.
Ja, okay, Entschuldigung.
Ja, ich erkläre es nochmal.
Also der Durchfall jetzt, das ist wässrig-schleimig.
Aber es ist kein Blut drin.
Also Essensreste und minimal.
Und eben so wässriger Schleim.
Okay.
Aber keine Blutbarnengen.
Und ich weiß nicht, ob das alle gesehen haben.
Es kam jetzt noch im Chat eine Frage dazu, die ich auch interessant finde.
Ob von der Familie jemand auch die gleichen Beschwerden hat.
Aber wir waren, also mein Mann war mit mir essen.
Und Freunde, und bei denen hat keiner was.
Ja, wie gesagt, mein Hausarzt hat ja diese Magenspiegelung gemacht,
weil ich ein bisschen Schmerzen hatte.
Und da, der hat gesagt, es käme nur vom Stress.
Ich sollte mal ein bisschen ruhiger werden.
Aber der konnte nichts mehr tun.
Und dann hat er gesagt, ich habe keine Angst.
Ich wollte mal ein bisschen ruhiger werden, aber der konnte nichts finden.
Okay, Sie haben keine Antibiotiktherapie?
Ich habe keine Tabletten oder was bekommen, nein.
Okay, danke schön.
Frau Bacca, gibt es ähnliche Beschwerden mit Ihnen, mit Ihren Kollegen oder Kolleginnen essen?
Die Frage habe ich gerade beantwortet.
Entschuldige.
Ich habe gesagt, die Frage ist im Chef gekommen, ob jemand, der mit dabei war,
oder aus der Familie jemand ähnliche Symptome hat.
Das habe ich gesagt.
Ich war mit meinem Mann und Freunden essen und niemand von denen hat irgendwas.
Ich bin der Einzige.
Okay, danke schön.
Frau Bacca, ist Ihnen ein Hautausschlag aufgefallen?
Ein Hautausschlag?
Ja, genau.
Mir hat es nicht aufgefallen.
Ja, okay. Keine Püri mehr.
Herr Doktor, Sie sagen Bescheid, wenn Sie so weit sind.
Mögen Sie schon weitermachen oder brauchen Sie noch ein bisschen?
Ja, eigentlich sind Sie ein bisschen braver.
Dann machen Sie noch. Ganz ruhig.
Ich trinke zu lange Tee.
Guten Appetit.
Frau Bacca, haben Sie einen wechselnden Stuhlgang?
Da meine ich zum Beispiel manchmal Durchfall.
Sie haben gesagt, mehrere Mal haben Sie Durchfall.
Aber hatten Sie auch manchmal Obstipation?
Nein, das eigentlich eher nicht.
Okay.
Das ist normal, keine Probleme.
Nur wenn ich mal Bauchschmerzen hatte.
Und wenn ich vielleicht auch mit dem Essen zusammen ging,
je nachdem, dass mir irgendwelches Essen nicht gut gekommen ist.
Dann habe ich halt auch mal Durchfall gehabt.
Okay.
Haben Sie Ihre Hausarztinnen nach Sie überweisen?
Nein, der hat mich jetzt nicht hierher überwiesen.
Der ist im Urlaub und deswegen bin ich direkt in die Notfallambulanz gekommen.
Ich möchte wissen, seit drei Tagen haben Sie fünf bis sechsmal täglich Durchfall.
Bevor, wieviel Mal haben Sie zum Beispiel, Sie haben gesagt,
dass ich habe immer gelegentlich Durchfall.
Zum Beispiel täglich zweimal, dreimal.
Das war dann vielleicht zweimal.
Und das war dann so, dass der Stuhl flüssig war.
Aber dass ich jetzt so wässrig über Tage Stuhl gegangen habe,
das kenne ich nicht mehr.
Okay, ich verstehe. Danke schön.
Bemerken Sie, nach dem Stuhlgang oder nach dem Erbrechen,
Ihre Schmerzen verbessert geworden?
Vielleicht hat man so ein bisschen das Gefühl der Erleichterung nach dem Erbrechen.
Oder auch wenn man was los geworden ist.
Eher Erleichterung vom Kopf her, würde ich sagen.
Aber dass die Schmerzen weniger sind, würde ich jetzt nicht unbedingt sagen.
Okay, danke schön.
Was meinen Sie, Herr Doktor? Sie haben Ihr Mikro wieder angestellt.
Sollen wir weitermachen?
Ja, okay. Guten Tag Frau Dr.
Ich möchte Ihnen einen neuen Patienten vorstellen.
Wen haben Sie denn gesehen?
Entschuldigung?
Welche Patienten haben Sie gesehen?
Die Patienten heißen Marianne Becker.
Es handelt sich um eine 36-jährige Patientin.
Sie bestellt sich heute wegen seit drei Tagen nach dem scharfen Lebensmittelernierung
krampfartig Bauchschmerzen in der Mitte des Oberbaus ohne Strahlung.
Sie haben täglich gleichzeitig sechsmal Durchfall, das wässrig und schleimig ist.
Sie erklärt heute zweimal Erbrechen.
Und die Erbrechen enthalten mal Essenreste.
Das Erbrochenen enthalten Essenreste.
Und sie bewertet die Bauchschmerzen auf der NRS mit 5 bis 10.
Sie bewertet die Bauchschmerzen auf der NRS mit 5 bis 10.
Ah ja, okay.
Sie hat gesagt, dass sie umgekehrt war und keine endgültigen Beschwerden hatten.
Die Bauchschmerzen haben keine Ausstrahlung.
Und die besonders krampfartige Bauchschmerzen, wenn sie zurückkommen,
sie haben keine Fieber.
Aber sie arbeiten in der Stressbelastung.
Sie arbeiten mit Stressbelastung?
Ja, sie arbeiten mit Stressbelastung.
Und es gibt keine Auffälligkeiten.
Keine Auffälligkeiten?
Keine Auffälligkeiten.
Sie haben seit zwei Jahren...
Ich glaube, irgendwie ist gerade unsere Verbindung schlecht.
Ich habe...
Zwei Jahre.
Ja, was hat sie seit zwei Jahren?
Sie leiden an Bluthochdrücken seit zwei Jahren.
Ja, habe ich gehört.
Sie nehmen dagegen Betablocker.
Betablocker, 2,5 mg.
Und sie nehmen...
Betablocker habe ich nicht wollen.
Nicht wollen, ich habe es nicht geschrieben.
Und sie nehmen regelmäßig Pille ein.
Und sie haben seit Kindheit mal eine Entfernung.
Und sie erklärt, sie haben deswegen irgendwelche Medikamente nicht eingenommen.
Also wegen der Schmerzen hat sie keine Medikamente genommen?
Ja, sie haben gesagt, sie haben keine Medikamente genommen.
Unsere Verbindung ist gerade schlecht. Ich kann sie nicht gut verstehen, Herr Doktor.
Hallo, Herr Doktor, ich kann sie nicht gut verstehen.
Ja, sie haben...
Können Sie noch einmal gucken, dass wir uns besser verständigen?
Ihr Bild steht auch für mich. Kann das sein, dass wir kein Internet haben?
Sie...
Können Sie mich noch hören?
Nee, weg ist er. Ich hoffe, er kommt gleich wieder. Ah, da ist er.
Ja.
Wir waren unterbrochen leider. Aber jetzt sind Sie wieder da.
Meine Damen und Herren, Sie rauchen keine Sehrauchung.
Sie trinken zwei oder drei Mal pro Woche ein oder zwei Klaren.
Sie sind verheiratet, eine gesunde Tochter.
Ihre Mutter leidet an Blutsuker Krankheit seit drei Jahren.
Ihr Vater leidet an Bluthochdruck und Vorhofffilma.
Sie haben nur Erdnüsse. Sie haben Allergie gegen nur Erdnüsse.
Nur Allergie gegen Erdnüsse, ja?
Nur Erdnüsse gegen Erdnüsse. Sie sind durch Luftnot und Yukreis ausgedrückt.
Ja, sehr gut.
Aufgrund der erhebenden anämistischen Angaben laut meinen Verdacht, Diagnose Gastroenteritis...
Was könnte es differenzial diagnostisch sein?
Gastroenteritis, Lebensmittelvergiftung nach dem Stammtun.
Der Patient hat sechs Monate eine Gastroskopie.
Wenn die Diagnose differenziert, wird die Gastrik ökoszentrikuliert.
Doch was? Das zweite habe ich nicht verstanden.
Ökoszentrikuliert oder?
Ökoszentrikuliert oder Do-Denum-Ventrikuliert.
Und Cholerithiasis, Cholerithiasis oder Cholestitis im Betracht.
Was machen Sie denn diagnostisch mit dem Patienten?
Ja, zuerst werde ich die Mitrperiometrie kontrollieren und körperliche Untersuchung.
Ich lege den Fokus auf den Bauchbereich, auf das Tastum.
Und ob es Abwehrschwung, Druckschmerz hat und ob es Schmerzen gibt.
Und zuerst, vor dem Papieren oder Tasten, sollte ich die Darmgeräusche abhören.
Und dann kann ich die Darmgeräusche aufstehen.
Im Labor werde ich Blut bilden.
Und dann mache ich die Stuhluntersuchung.
Ja, aber im Blut. Machen Sie außer dem Blutbild noch etwas anderes?
Machen Sie mal die Blutuntersuchung, außer dem Blutbild noch etwas anderes.
Und dann kann ich die Elektrolytik und die Nierenwerte und die Lebewerte durchführen lassen.
Und zuerst werde ich die Kultur durchführen lassen.
Und das bildgebende Verfahren.
Welches bildgebende Verfahren bietet sich an?
Ja, das ist ein Ultraschall.
Gut, dann halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden über die Patienten.
Was würde man denn noch abklären, vielleicht mit einem weiteren aufwendigen technischen Verfahren?
Entschuldigung, ich habe nicht verstanden.
Welches Verfahren würde sich zur weiteren Diagnostik noch anbieten?
Ja, Gastroskopie können wir für diese Patienten nicht auszuschließen.
Und was würde man da bei der Gelegenheit gleich mit testen?
Ja, das ist die Urease-Schnelltestung.
Ja, genau.
Was würde man unternehmen, wenn Helikobakter positiv ist?
Entschuldigung, wenn Helikobakter nachgewiesen ist?
Ja, Urease positiv, ich denke das.
Bitte was?
Wenn der Helikobakter-Pyloid nachgewiesen ist, was macht man dann?
Ich denke, das ist die Behandlung.
Ja, was würde man für eine Therapie machen?
Ja, wir sollten drei Medikamenten-Therapien empfehlen.
Zwei Antibiotika sind Claritromisin, Amoxicillin und Protonpumpen.
Sehr gut, ja. Okay, gut. Das sind die Standardfragen zu diesem Fall.
Das musste kommen. Sehr schön.
Halten Sie mich bitte auf dem Laufenden über die Patienten.
Dann schauen wir uns die nachher noch mal zusammen an.
Glauben Sie, muss die stationär bleiben?
Nein, ich denke, dass bei der Körperliere diese Patienten habe ich zweimal erbrochen.
Und ich denke, dass die Patienten trinken.
Sie kann trinken, klar. Sie kann selber Füßigkeit aufhören.
Ja, kann man. Aber wir sollten bei der Körperliere untersuchen.
Also normalerweise würde man nicht.
Also die Qualität unserer Verbindung...
Ja, die Tröckchen sind zweimal.
Ich habe keine ganzen Sätze mehr hier von Ihnen. Ich kriege immer nur so Stückchen.
Die Verbindung ist irgendwie schlecht.
Aber ich glaube, wir haben uns schon dahingehend verstanden,
dass die Patientin normalerweise nach Hause gehen kann.
Ist er noch da? Ja.
Dass die Patientin normalerweise nach Hause gehen kann.
Aber nur wenn es Komplikationen gäbe, müsste sie da bleiben.
Ja, besonders.
Gut, ja. Dann lassen wir uns schauen, was mir aufgefallen ist an unserem Gespräch.
Eigentlich sind Sie in der Anamnese und im Bericht sehr konsequent bei der Sache geblieben.
Was mir auffällt, dass wir einmal natürlich technisch Verständigungsprobleme hatten.
Dass mit einmal die Verbindung schlecht war und dass ich nachfragen musste.
Aber ich glaube, Sie haben auch nicht immer alles verstanden, was ich gesagt habe.
Und dass wir so ein bisschen aneinander vorbei geredet haben, das will man eigentlich nicht.
Mir sind ein paar grammatikalische Besonderheiten aufgefallen.
Aber jetzt muss ich gucken, ob ich das noch lesen kann, was ich mir aufgeschrieben habe.
Die Patientin beschreibt Schmerzen ohne Strahlung.
Ohne Ausstrahlung.
Sie fragen nach, strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Das Verb ist ausstrahlen, ein trennbares Verb.
Also das Nomen ist die Ausstrahlung.
Also strahlen die Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus, also ohne Ausstrahlung.
Oh Gott, jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr, in welchen Zusammen...
Ja, ich kriege das nicht mehr ganz hin.
Aber im Arztgespräch haben Sie dann berichtet, Sie haben sehr konsequent den Konjunktiv angewendet.
Das haben Sie also vorbildlich wirklich wahr.
Also Sie habe und Sie sei und was auch immer.
Und dann die Patientin berichtet, dass die Schmerzen hatten, was ich nach dem Essen begonnen habe.
Dass die Schmerzen nach dem Essen begonnen hatten.
Also Verb nach hinten im Nebensatz.
Das ist diese doofe und komplizierte Wortstellung in deutschen Sätzen.
Hauptsätze, Verb an zweiter Stelle, Nebensätze, Verb nach hinten.
Und dann ein Klassiker.
Ein Klassiker kommt immer wieder vor.
Tondylektomie als Kindheit.
Nee, in der Kindheit.
Oder als Kind.
Als Kind oder in der Kindheit.
Das wird gern genommen, kommt immer wieder vor.
Sie machen tatsächlich noch relativ viel grammatikalische Fehler.
Und nach wie vor ist die Aussprache so, dass man sich sehr, sehr, sehr konzentrieren muss, um sie zu verstehen.
Ich meine, es ist besser als beim letzten Mal.
Denke ich schon. Es ist ein bisschen besser.
Aber es ist immer noch so, dass man sich wirklich sehr anstrengen muss, um bei der Sache zu bleiben.
Das Licht liegt vielleicht jetzt auch so ein bisschen an meiner Müdigkeit.
Es ist schon spät am Abend.
Was immer besonders kompliziert ist, ist die Wiedergabe dieser ersten Anamneseschritte.
Da fehlte auch wieder im Satz irgendwas.
Die Patientin stellte sich vor wegen irgendwas.
Und das war auch wieder ein Satz, der nicht so ganz zu Ende gebracht war.
Aber das ist natürlich immer das Problem, dass man in diesen ersten Satz eigentlich schon mal so viel Informationen reinpacken will.
Ich empfehle ja immer, lieber nur zwei, drei Informationen in den ersten Satz reinzupacken.
Und dann lieber mit neuen Sätzen zu ergänzen.
Dann ist mir positiv aufgefallen, dass sie a. die Patientin immer mal wieder mit Namen angesprochen haben.
Das ist immer sehr schön.
Und b. dass sie praktisch auf das eingegangen sind, was sie schon vorher gesagt hat.
Sie haben also nicht stumpf gefragt, was sie auf ihrem Zettel haben, sondern sie haben gesagt, sie haben vorher gesagt das.
Das heißt, sie haben zugehört, haben sich gemerkt, was sie gesagt hat und gehen darauf ein.
Das finde ich sehr, sehr positiv. So etwas ist für Prüfer ein wichtiges Kriterium.
Ich denke eigentlich, dass sie die Situation schon grundlegend wiedergegeben haben.
Eine Sache, die ich jetzt gerade noch eingekröselt sehe.
Die Patientin hat ja gesagt, sie hatte schon länger, dass sie nach bestimmtem Essen irgendwie dann auch mal Durchfälle hat.
Sie ist sonst nicht verstopft, aber sonst hat sie eben normale Verdauung.
Aber hin und wieder hat sie schon mal so kräftige Durchfälle.
Und da hat sie auch Schmerzen.
Das hat sie auch gesagt. Sie hat schon häufiger mal Bauchschmerzen nach bestimmtem Essen.
Und da haben sie gesagt, ähnliche Beschwerden hatte sie vorher nicht.
Das ist nicht so ganz korrekt, aber ansonsten denke ich mal, war die Wiedergabe okay.
Auch was die Sozialanamnese, Familienanamnese und Vorerkrankungen angeht.
Das passt alles.
Und mit der Diagnose sind sie natürlich völlig auf dem richtigen Pfad.
Tatsächlich war dies eine Patientin mit Ulcosventrikulie.
Hatten sie in ihren Differentialdiagnosen drin. Ja, okay, alles klar.
Gut, also so ein paar Schönheitsfehler haben wir noch.
Versuchen Sie noch ein bisschen zu schleifen an Ihren Formulierungen.
Was ich auch wichtig finde, dass Sie eben zum Beispiel so etwas sagen,
seit zwei Jahren ist eine Hypertonus bekannt.
Und dass Sie eben nicht sagen, Bluthochdruck.
Dass Sie einfach die Fachterminologie schon einbringen, zumindest streckenweise.
Ich weiß jetzt nicht, wie speziell die Hamburger sind.
In einigen Prüfungskommissionen, die wollen praktisch durchgehen,
die Fachbegriffe im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch, aber natürlich nicht im Arzt-Patienten-Gespräch.
Da ist es ja wiederum nahezu verpönt, weil man davon ausgeht,
der Patient ist ein bisschen blöd.
Aber im Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch sollten die Fachbegriffe schon kommen.
Und das kann man sich vielleicht auch noch mal so ein bisschen aneignen.
Was mir natürlich aufgefallen ist, dass Sie relativ oft immer noch
haben Sie gefragt haben. Hab ich glaube ich letztes Mal auch schon gesagt.
Und das auch ziemlich viel so verlegen kommt.
Aber da muss ich Sie trösten.
Das machen so viele Leute, auch Muttersprachler machen das.
Und wenn man mal sieht, wie Leute ganz offiziell Politiker oder irgendwelche Redner oder so,
wie die formulieren, wenn die nicht ganz geschliffen und gut sind, die ansprachen,
dann machen die genau dieselben Fehler.
Gerade wenn sie spontan formulieren sollen, wenn die so in Interviews Fragen bekommen,
dann machen die auch äh und machen falsche Sätze.
Also kann passieren. Ist kein Beingriff.
Verständigung ja noch so ein bisschen ein Haken, aber ich denke mal für heute Abend
können Sie zufrieden sein. Ja.
Vielen Dank.
Gut. Ja, ich bedanke mich bei Ihnen allen sehr herzlich überhaupt, dass Sie dabei waren.
Das war toll. Auch wieder sehr engagierte Mitarbeit nachfragen.
Das ist für mich jedes Mal immer so ein Zeichen.
Sie lassen sich da nicht nur berieseln und sagen ja erzählen wir machen mal,
sondern alle arbeiten mit und denken mit.
Und das ist richtig klasse. Das macht Spaß.
Und ich freue mich, dass wir uns heute Abend treffen konnten.
Und Dienstag wird es wahrscheinlich nichts werden.
Donnerstag werde ich wahrscheinlich abends spät zu Hause sein.
Könnte sein, dass ich es noch schaffe.
Also heute in einer Woche könnte sein, dass ich da was anbieten kann.
Da würde ich mich aber von unterwegs melden.
Je nachdem, was die Deutsche Bahn auch so an Überraschungen für mich bereithält.
Da kann man ja zurzeit bunte Geschichten erleben,
dass man irgendwie auf der Strecke hängen bleibt.
Insofern versuche ich also, dass ich am Donnerstag da bin.
Ich melde mich aber noch vorher. Ja.
Gut. Ihnen allen einen schönen Abend.
Machen Sie das Beste aus den nächsten Tagen.
Und gutes Wochenende, wenn es dann soweit ist.
Und wir hören und sehen uns vielleicht in einer Woche.
Tschüss zusammen und vielen Dank für heute Abend.
Vielen Dank. Schönen Abend.